okay today I'm going to talk to you
about Yuja fication so what unification
is is something which can negatively
impact an ecosystem and can decrease the
biodiversity the biodiversity just means
the range of different living organisms
within an ecosystem so let me explain
how it works so here at the moment we
have a healthy lake we've got fish we've
got aquatic plants there's the Sun up
here and this is a farmer's field right
next to the lake so first of all what
the farmer does is he puts or he or she
puts nitrates onto the crops so nitrates
are just type of fertilizers that or
within fertilizers that encourage plants
to grow so what happens is this so the
nitrates are put on the crops now when
it rains when it rains lots of these
nitrates what happens to them is they're
actually washed into the rivers and
lakes now the effect that this has is
this on the surface of rivers and lakes
there's this there are these plants
called algae so it's just a plan that
goes slogan of floats on the surface of
a lake now nitrate encourage plant
growth so when the nitrates wash in it
causes the algae to grow all the way
along the surface of the water now this
is a big problem because at the bottom
of the water we have all of these
aquatic plants now what has happened
because the algae is now grown across
the whole surface of the water the light
from the Sun can no longer get to these
plants at the bottom of the river or the
lake as a result these plants die
because they can't photosynthesize
photosynthesize because remember for
photosynthesis to occur for
photosynthesis to occur they need light
so all of these plants at the bottom of
the lake die now that has a negative
effect on the water because first of all
plants normally give out oxygen during
photosynthesis
and they take in carbon dioxide so if
the plants die it means they will not be
releasing any oxygen and they will be
they will be not taking as much carbon
dioxide so this will mean there'll be
less oxygen the water and less carbon
dioxide in the water
what's also problem is when these plants
die now this is the stage people often
forget so listen carefully when these
plants die
lots of micro organisms so remember
micro organisms just a tiny living thing
micro organisms come along and break
down all of these dead plants now
because micro organisms are living
things they respire and as they do they
take in some of the oxygen from the
water and they release more co2 so this
means we've now got a really really low
level of oxygen in the water because
because the plants aren't releasing any
oxygen because they can't
photosynthesize they're dead and these
microorganisms are taking an oxygen as
well this is bad news for these fish
here because these fish and other
aquatic life in there that need oxygen
in order to respire robic lee they are
going to die so we could see here that
our ecosystem has been completely
transformed because the nitrates got
into this and into the water
it encouraged algae to grow all the way
across the surface Sun couldn't get to
the aquatic plants so they died this
meant there was less oxygen in the water
microorganisms broke down the plants and
took even more oxygen from the water and
this caused other aquatic life to die
this shows that there's been a real big
decrease in the biodiversity within this
area because so many are so much of the
aquatic organisms have died as a result
thank you very much